bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur arte france vous avez donc été
convoqués cette semaine au quai d'orsay
quelle explication avez vous apporté
pour justifier la situation de
l'ambassadeur français à caracas jeunes
et industrie cassions exactement je suis
convoqué trois fois par le quai d'orsay
et c'est une chance inouïe et tout la
première fois depuis les relations
bilatérales entre les jeunes soldats
français et trois fois dans la semaine
il explique les gemmes aux autorités
françaises qui les coupures d'eau et
d'électricité
c'est une chose qui touche tous les
vénézuéliens même à côté de l'ambassade
de l'incident de la résidence de france
à canach se trouve la résidence de la
flûte du site
ils ont été touchés avec le problème des
épisodes de l'esprit de haut de gamme
excédent et même le consulat général d
italie mais aussi de l'espagne se trouve
dans la même situation elle a dit des
témoins ont fait vriller dernier à son
retour d'une tournée diplomatique juan
ubaldo l'opposant président nicholas
maduro est revenu à caracas il a été
accueilli à la descente d'avion par des
diplomates européens et notamment
français
que répondez-vous donc aujourd'hui à
ceux qui pointent du doigt une tension
diplomatique entre le venezuela et la
france et par là même un acte d'ordre un
politique des représailles pour
expliquer ce traitement réservé qui
serait réservé à l'ambassadeur français
à caracas ce n'est pas la première fois
que l'on bat corps malade soit se réunit
avec
et le président santos choisi par les
etats-unis et par le pays de l'union
européenne comme quelqu'un qui doit
entériner écornée mais les élections au
20h au moci lui et quelques pouvoirs
pour le faire et cette étrange je veux
ajouter quelque chose
si les autorités françaises ont un
problème électrique touche d'électricité
d'eau de gaz
pourquoi ils nous ont ils n'ont pas
aller parler avec mon horizon parce que
exactement l'état vénézuélien et les
gouvernements nationaux et les kings les
gars honnête gouvernement du président
amadou et l'autre monsieur et madame x
mais ce qui a fait et des fois que je ne
sais pas plus et voir l'ambassadeur de
france à karak c'est une claire procès
et un stratégie de provocation dans des
rêves et des immixtions dans les
affaires intérieures du venezuela
c'est à lille s'est fait une chose qui
ne respectent pas les conventions bbm
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions michel maury
carlon bassin ambassadeur du venezuela
en france